throughout the russian revolution many
of you will know that the bolsheviks
weren't the only communist group
involved
in fact another group the mensheviks had
a major part to play in for much of 1917
they stood firmly opposed to the
bolsheviks in many ways
yet as you'll know it was the bolsheviks
who ran russia in the wake of the
revolution and not the mensheviks which
raises the obvious question
why why did the mensheviks lose out to
the bolsheviks
so to begin it's important to note that
the two used to be part of the same
political party the russian social
democratic labour party
after some small ideological
disagreements in 1903 this party broke
into two parts
the first led by vladimir lenin was the
bolsheviks meaning majority
the second led by julius martov was the
mensheviks meaning minority
when world war one broke out in 1914 the
mensheviks and the bolsheviks were both
firmly opposed and when public opinion
started to turn against the war and the
tsar both smelled an opportunity
when the romanovs were ousted and the
february revolution was completed russia
had a brand new government
well actually it had two the provisional
government which had the support of the
remaining russian state and its old
allies
and the petrograd soviet which was a
rival government made up of the
mensheviks the bolsheviks and many of
the socialist revolutionaries
and side note for about a month both of
these governments were housed in the
same building
which must have been quite awkward given
that the coming revolution was just down
the hall to the left
at first the petrograd soviet was
dominated by the mensheviks for the most
part they believed that the best course
forward in order to establish
a communist state was to support the
provisional government because they felt
that russia's economy wasn't
sufficiently developed enough to make
the leap to communism and instead it
needed to go through the industrial
capitalism bit first
whereas the bolsheviks had very
different ideas on how to achieve
a communist state in the end the
mensheviks even ended up taking cabinet
positions and most notably supported the
continuation of russia's involvement in
world war one
and this was a fatal mistake since the
basis of authority for the mensheviks
within the provisional government was
the support
of the soldiery this led to a breakdown
in cooperation between the bolsheviks
and the mensheviks and importantly saw
the bolsheviks rapidly gain support
in july some of their supporters
attempted to overthrow the government
which failed and as a result the
provisional government including the
mensheviks cracked down on the
bolsheviks
leading to the arrest of summon forcing
lenin into exile
it wasn't long afterwards that there was
an attempted military coup which failed
but most people saw the government as
complicit in it
as such many people now turn to the
bolsheviks and things got even more
tense
leading to lenin returning because it
was time for revolution number two
as you'll know this one saw the
bolsheviks placed in complete control
providing you ignored the long and
incredibly brutal civil war that
followed
as the war progressed the bolsheviks who
were now calling themselves the
communist party centralized power and
removed the mensheviks and other
leftists from government positions
this expulsion didn't mean the end of
the mensheviks though
as a result many went south to georgia
and briefly round the country until it
was conquered by the reds in 1921
and in the same year a group of
disenfranchised sailors on the island of
kronstadt just here launched a rebellion
against the government
it was mostly an anarchist one but there
were some left-wing sympathies amongst
the rebels and so after crushing the
revolt the communists promptly used it
as an excuse to ban all other competing
parties in the country
menshevism had finally lost out to
bolshevism
i hope you enjoyed this episode and
thank you for watching with a special
thanks to my patrons james bissonette
sam kelly moneymaker the pastry section
danny maloney
moe marvin cassell rob waterhouse james
castaneda jordan longley spinning three
plates gustav swann jerry lamdin rasheed
ali marcus asner izzy
maggie paxkowski cooling castleman david
silverman coppertone anthony beckett
matthew shipley
lexy schwinn robert wetzel skye
chappelle winston cayward aaron the
white spencer lightfoot and fobo joe